actress Gwyneth Paltrow is at it again
with her nonsense
pseudoscience and I mean again because
I've previously told you about some of
her antics which I just find so
destructive
I hate pseudoscience I'm disgusted by
products and services that take
advantage of people but for me it's
especially bad when people use their
celebrity to promote this nonsense
because by too many people it's seen as
credibility when someone like Gwyneth
Paltrow promotes X Y or Z product or
scam on her website and some people get
this but there's lots of people who say
to themselves well if Gwyneth Paltrow is
promoting it it must be good or it must
be honest or it must be real because the
risk to her of promoting something
that's a scam it's too big she would
never do that those are the same people
who believe you don't need any
regulation because no business would
ever do something wrong because they'd
get caught and it would be bad for them
yeah I'm sure she's just getting paid
very well to sign her name off on this I
would not be surprised to hear that and
back in June I told you that Gwyneth
Paltrow's website called goop yeah
that's the name of it goop it
recommended all sorts of nonsense
products and so-called treatments it
included something called vaginal
steaming where women would squat above
steaming water that contained herbs like
mugwort rosemary wormwood and basil it's
sort of an alternative health practice
her website is filled with all sorts of
claims about products that will balance
your energy or their cleansing or
they'll balance your hormones or
whatever you've seen this type of stuff
she sells she has an advertiser that
sells healing stickers which you can buy
through her website it's 60 bucks for a
pack of 10 and you'll be glad to know
that they come pre-programmed to ideal
frequencies to promote healing by
addressing imbalances in your body that
was back in June okay the latest is that
she's endorsing coffee enemas right
she's gone fully now in and doctors are
for good reason very very worried about
this her goop website tells you that you
can quote supercharge your detox with a
do-it-yourself coffee enema for a
hundred and thirty five dollars now the
idea of colonics and enemas for detox
purpose
including with coffee it's been around
for a while no medical or scientific
evidence supports it and some will hear
me say that and they'll say David the
reason there's no scientific evidence
supporting coffee enemas is that the
corporate pharma world doesn't want it
to be known that it's so good
because then people would do that and
then the companies would lose money no
not only is there no evidence that it
does anything good there is evidence you
can hurt yourself if you put liquids
that are too hot inside of yourself you
can do serious damage to yourself in
best case scenario there's no benefits
whatsoever okay so it's a coffee enema
right website goop yep and it's a
hundred and thirty five dollars yes and
people buy this stuff well I assume that
someone must be buying it because it's a
company that exists and they're paying
for advertising on goop on her goop
website uh so in Canada because any
product that makes a health claim has to
have a license there's actually more
attention being paid to this in Canada
than in the United States but there are
ways that these companies can skirt
around these requirements by using
particularly vague language and Gwyneth
Paltrow
seems really focused on selling this
stuff and I was actually thinking
vaginal steaming yeah coffee enemas
right it's a lot of stuff that relates
to putting things inside of your
genitals or rectum quite the market
there it's a weird thing it's a really
really weird thing come on people coffee
is meant to be enjoyed
in your living room sitting outside of a
Parisian cafe but not in your rectum
that is not the way to enjoy a good cup
of coffee and there are people who even
though they agree that this is nonsense
they say well listen there shouldn't be
no regulation that's a nanny state
everybody should be free to decide for
themselves what's good or bad I tend to
disagree because when you have people as
well known as Gwyneth Paltrow with the
platforms that she has I think it's okay
for regulators to say hold on we're
gonna apply some logic here and we're
gonna just do a little bit to try to
protect consumers so folks no coffee
enemas please yeah it was a five dollar
coffee enema then we're having a
conversation right that's more like five
that's more like Starbucks right I go
and get your your you know Frappuccino
and we
whatever yeah or do you get a $5 coffee
enema but $135 coffee enema come on
folks be reasonable the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as one dollar per month and
every dollar helps to support the work
that we're doing particularly in light
of the YouTube ad boycott which has been
really bad